so there's a fantastic interview with
George Carlin when he's talking about
how he gets some of his greatest ideas
and how he achieved such brilliance in
his comedy in such success and so he
talked about this concept known as
psycho cybernetics and psycho
cybernetics has to do with a way of
programming your brain to exploit its
pattern recognizing capacities in other
words the brain is a goal seeking
mechanism he says and so he talks about
you know creating a set of impressions
in your brain sort of pre-decide the
kind of patterns it's gonna be on the
lookout for so the first idea of course
is come up with an idea think of a joke
come up with an insight you know there's
the initial impression the initial
creative thought and so impression
number one is the moment you think of it
impression number two is write it down
record it and you know transcribe it
that's impression number two impression
number three is review your notes later
in the day go through the things you've
thought about look at the digital paper
trail of everything you wrote down and
everything you thought of and then after
those three impressions the initial
thought they're writing it down and be
reflecting upon later you've imprinted
in your brain that meta pattern and then
later on that day that week that
whatever you're gonna start connecting
the dots everywhere you go you're gonna
have serendipitous encounters with
things that are connected to that
initial idea go to a bookstore and every
book you open to any single page will
will reveal the clue and it's
essentially again you essentially you're
priming your brain to find patterns and
connections to this particular thing
it's a way of cultivating curiosity and
cultivating sort of mind maps and neural
networks in a way and then again you
find that the world is indeed full of
clues and you can read your way through
it you just have to you have to figure
out what you're looking for and you got
a program that into your subconscious so
that's a psycho cybernetics cool